m
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlements
enzo est le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire est notre
invité aujourd'hui jean noël barrot
bonjour bienvenue elle vous êtes député
modem est des yvelines bonjour à vous
oriane bonjour marion et au menu cette
semaine
il veut en faire une tradition pour la
deuxième fois de son quinquennat
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé devant les
parlementaires réunis en congrès à
versailles
bilan de la première année perspectives
pour l'année à venir et une annonce il
souhaite modifier la constitution pour
pouvoir désormais assister au discours
des parlementaires et leur répondre
la modification de la constitution il en
a justement été question toute la
semaine dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
les parlementaires examinent le volet
constitutionnel de la réforme des
institutions c'est le premier ministre
qui a lancé les débats défendant un
texte renforçant le lien entre les
français la démocratie l'opposition
dénonce elle un affaiblissement du
parlement jamais vu depuis 1958 et au
même moment le sénat examine l'une des
réformes majeures du quinquennat la loi
et nico réformant l'assurance chômage la
formation professionnelle et
l'apprentissage
mais une phrase prononcée par emmanuel
macron lors du congrès a enflammé les
débats
le chef de l'état souhaite que les
partenaires sociaux revoit les règles de
l'assurance chômage et lundi emmanuel
macron a donc lancé l'an ii de son
quinquennat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à versailles devant le congrès manuel
maquereau a donc défendu pendant 1h30 la
première année de son quinquennat il a
répondu aux critiques avant de fixer les
priorités de l'an 2 l amont bagarre à
emmanuel macron l'avait promis il
rendrait compte de son action devant le
congrès chaque année monsieur le
président de la république vous avez la
parole alors devant députés et sénateurs
il fait la liste des réformes engagées
depuis un an
façon aussi de souligner le travail des
parlementaires
votre action a permis que
l'investissement reparte
vous avez rendu à la france ses
capacités militaires vous avez levé les
blocages du marché du travail
vous avez sauvé d'une faillite certaine
notre service public du transport mais
le président de la république le sait il
est attendu sur un éventuel tournant
social lui que l'opposition appelle le
président des riches
je n'aime ni les castes ni les rentes ni
les privilèges
ce n'est pas le petit nombre qui
m'importe mais la communauté de nos
concitoyens de la base au sommet de
l'échelle sociale
alors il insiste sur la lutte contre les
inégalités et la réduction de la
pauvreté il y a une voix françaises vers
l'inégalité
elle progresse depuis plus de 30 ans il
ne s'agit pas comme chez nombre de nos
voisins d'une inégalité de revenus même
si elles existent non ceux qui s'est
installée avant tout en france ce sont
les inégalités de destin je veux d'une
stratégie de lutte contre la pauvreté
qui ne permettent pas à nos concitoyens
pauvres de vivre mieux mais bien de
sortir de la pauvreté
une bonne fois pour toutes pourtant pas
question de renier la première année de
son mandat
emmanuel macron assume si l'on veut
partager le gâteau
la première condition est qu'il y est un
gâteau et ce sont les entreprises
assemblant actionnaires dirigeants des
travailleurs ce sont les producteurs qui
font ce gâteau et personne d'autre
le président entend enfin d'éteindre la
récente polémique sur les pensions de
réversion
je le dis clairement
rien ne changera pour les retraités
d'aujourd'hui rien 1h32 discours de la
pédagogie sur les réformes en cours des
précisions sur le calendrier mais aucune
nouvelle annonce lors de ce discours
devant koré emmanuel macron l'a débuté
par un mea culpa plutôt étonnante sa
part il a dit je sais que je ne réussis
pas tout qu'est ce qui a échoué
non il a il a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas
qu'on ne pouvait pas tout réussir
c'était simplement la marque d'une forme
d'humilité de l'homme qui malgré je
dirais le tout le respect qui est dû à
sa fonction de président de la
république est bien peu comme être
parfois des erreurs ou en tout cas peut
ne pas toujours avoir raison
alors que c'est le reproche qui lui est
fait souvent que de ne pas savoir bien
écouter les autres il a commencé par
dire qu'il est qui qui pouvait tout à
fait le faire c'était simplement aucun
échec pendant cette première année du
quinquennat
vous savez évidemment qu'il y aura des
politiques publiques qui ont été mises
en oeuvre des réformes qui ont été
engagées qui ne porteront pas leurs
fruits
et d'ailleurs mais emmanuel macron quand
il était candidat ne s'en est pas caché
puisque c'est lui même qui a dit que
l'évaluation et le contrôle de nos
politiques publiques seraient au coeur
de l'exercice démocratique est donc tout
ce que nous faisons nous allons
l'évaluer et ce qui marche bien nous
amplifierons ce qui ne marche pas et
bien nous les corrigerons pour françois
bayrou et emmanuel macron à fixer un cap
compréhensible c'est aussi votre
sentiment pour sept ans 2 qui s'annonce
absolument il a dit qu'il fallait que
nous puissions construire un état
providence pour le 21e siècle
il a dit qu'il souhaitait que les la
condition sociale ne soit pas commander
je dirais par les situations familiales
par le réseau mémé par le mérite par
l'effort et je crois qu'il ya là
une une réponse qui a apporté à la tente
qui avait été exprimée par françois
bayrou mais aussi par toute une partie
de la majorité qui souhaitent que nous
saisissions l'occasion de ce quinquennat
pour mettre en place des nouvelles
protections dont les françaises et
français ont besoin pour le monde qui
vient mais a tout de même une tentation
libéral dans ce discours il faut certes
redistribuer mais aussi responsabiliser
ce sont les mots du président oui enfin
libéral je ne sais pas à la question de
la responsabilité je pense que nous
sommes de très nombreux parlementaires
sur sur deux sur tous les bancs a à nous
dire que il y a quelque chose à réformer
dans notre dans l'état dans notre
protection sociale
et ce n'est pas parce que on active
comme on dit les dépenses sociales c'est
à dire qu on les oriente vers la reprise
de l'emploi en responsabilisant les
personnes qu'on entre pour autant vers
le libéralisme donc il n'y a pas de
sujet de ce point de vue là alors si
vous aussi le président vous a convaincu
jean noël barrot tous les députés
sénateurs ne l'ont pas été car
l'opposition reste dans la tente d'un
tournant social et d'un discours qui
s'adresse aux français
écoutez ces quelques réactions moi je
décrypte assez bien le maquereau nisme
je peux vous dire que si les français
ont aimé l'année dernière ils vont
adorer l'année prochaine parce que en
matière de brutalité sociale
ils vont avoir leur compte entre la
réforme de la retraite qu'il a annoncé
entre la réforme des minima sociaux et
la réforme de l'indemnisation du chômage
croyez moi ça n'a pas fini de tanguay et
les déceptions n'ont pas fini de
s'accumulent
voilà un président qui marche sur une
seule jambe et je le dis souvent s'il y
avait une jambe gauche
ce serait une jambe de bois aujourd'hui
on voit qu'il ya même pas de jambes de
moi y'a rien globalement je trouve que
ce discours et je ne suis pas un
professeur est en progrès est meilleur
que celui de l'an dernier dans le ton 1
il ya moins il n'ya pas y a pas
d'arrogance n'y a pas de grandes
envolées lyriques ou alors juste ce
qu'il faut moi je les trouvais plutôt
pas mal
on est toujours dans cet exercice du
pouvoir extrêmement autocentré en aidant
cette verticalité du pouvoir dont j'ai
pu dire que quand on sait de vertige là
en réalité on quittait ce que les
français souhaitaient voilà je pense que
là il ya une une limite qui a été
franchie on vient d'entendre bruno
retailleau emmanuel macron lors de ce
congrès a annoncé qu'il souhaitait une
modification de la constitution pour
désormais pouvoir écouter les
parlementaires et leur répondre est ce
que ça ne va pas renforcer ce que disait
bruno retailleau ce côté autocentré du
pouvoir cette hyperprésidentialisation
écouter ce sont les républicains eux
mêmes qui ont déposé un amendement pour
solliciter 7
cette possibilité cette écoute c'est
cette réponse du président de la
république donc je crois que ça va tout
à fait dans le sens de ce que disait
monsieur retailleau mais pour réagir à
certains des points qui ont été qui ont
été évoqués à la fois par le front
national leur assemblée nationale mais
aussi par la nouvelle gauche ce qui a
été proposé jusqu'à présent depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années c'est de
dire il y a un certain nombre
d'inégalités qui apparaissent et qui
sont lus et aux grandes mutations du
monde et nous devons les corriger en je
dirais en déployant des des dispositifs
qui ne vise pas à apporter des réponses
définitives mais plutôt à je dirais à
atténuer à atténuer les effets du mal
la proposition qui est porté par la
majorité par emmanuel macron c'est de
s'attaquer aux racines du mal et dire
qu'il n'ya pas de jambe gauche ou en
tout cas dire qu'il n'y a pas de projet
social
c'est une erreur il ya déjà eu des
éléments très importants qui ont été
reconnus d'ailleurs par les français en
matière d'éducation avec le dédoublement
des classes de cp en ré plus en matière
de protection des personnes en situation
de handicap et les personnes âgées avec
la réalisation de l'allocation adulte
handicapé et les minimes et les minima
vieillesse et donc il y a une véritable
ambition qui va se prolonger avec le
plan de lutte contre la pauvreté avec la
protection des demandeurs d'emploi et la
formation tout au long de la vie donc il
ya véritablement pourquoi ça ne prime
pas alors jean noël barrot pourquoi il a
toujours cette étiquette de président
des riches
je sais pas s'il a cette étiquette de
président des riches je crois que ces
protections
m je dirais un peu plus de temps à je
dirais à se construire se mettre en
place qu'un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises au début du
quinquennat pour libérer l'économie ces
mesures-là ont pris effet immédiatement
les mesures de protection vont monter en
puissance et les françaises et les
français
eh bien ils ont pris l'habitude d'être
déçus par les promesses des responsables
politiques ou même ils ont pris
l'habitude de voir des politiques
publiques qui étaient décidées à
l'assemblée nationale mais qui n'étaient
pas appliquées sur le terrain et donc ce
n'est uniquement que lorsque ils verront
les effets concrets de ces politiques
lorsqu'il le zant est bien quand à
partir du 1er juillet janvier 2019 les
démissionnaires pourront bénéficier
d'une protection
de d'indemnisation chômage que les
indépendants pourront également qu'à ce
moment là
eh bien ils reconnaîtront que les
protections bien été mise en place on va
passer à la réforme des institutions
examiné cette semaine dans l'hémicycle
de l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux semaines de débats de 1400
amendement l'assemblée débute donc
l'examen de la partie constitutionnel de
la vaste réforme des institutions elle a
notamment modifié le très symbolique
article premier fonds dans les valeurs
de la république
nathalie gloire c'est à l'unanimité que
les députés supprime le mot race de la
constitution un premier vote symbolique
dans le débat de la réforme des
institutions qui a débuté ce mardi à
l'assemblée
cet amendement présenté par le groupe
udi agir et indépendant est soutenue par
le gouvernement
supprimer le mot race est donc
évidemment un symbole puissant mais
aussi une évidence à laquelle le
gouvernement ne peut que souscrire pour
autant il ne faut pas que cela conduise
à fragiliser notre arsenal juridique qui
nous permet de lutter contre le racisme
cet amendement a été voté à l'unanimité
des 119 députés présents même si le
député jean christophe lagarde a
regretté l'absence des députés d'extrême
droite
donc oui il ya eu unanimité de cette
assemblée nationale à l'exception des
députés d'extrême droite qui avait mieux
à faire paraît-il
au moment où nous faisions cet acte fort
et cet acte symbolique ils n'étaient pas
absents par manque de volonté il était
absent par volonté pour ne pas être
inclus dans ce débat qui pourtant honore
notre nation la ministre de la justice
nicole belloubet a remercié les élus
pour leur vote
un vote qui a vu certains députés je
veux vraiment ça lieu ce moment qui est
un moment extrêmement important de
l'élévation de la conscience collective
c'est un moment historique je ne savais
pas que je serais aussi aimions
participants la suppression d'un mot
cette suppression est accompagné de
l'interdiction de la distinction de sexe
désormais dans l'article 1
la france assurera l'égalité devant la
loi de tous les citoyens sans
distinction de ce
ex d'origine ou de religion cette
formulation sera définitive que si la
révision constitutionnelle à bout
jean-noël eux à barreaux la suppression
de ce mot race de la constitution et
symbolique était ce nécessaire
je crois que c'était nécessaire et
effectivement à l'heure où est bien un
certain nombre de jeux dirait de
discours se développe que d'affirmer
très fortement sur le texte fondateur de
notre république
cette cette valeur là donc je suis très
heureux même si je n'étais pas dans
l'hémicycle à ce moment là que mes
collègues députés à l'unanimité se soit
exprimé pas de risque de fragiliser
juridiquement la lutte contre le racisme
c'est ce qu'ont dit certains députés
notamment l air et de la france
insoumise non je ne crois pas que ce
risque là soit soirée elle je crois
simplement que c'est la reconnaissance
par la constitution qu'il n'y a pas de
distinction qui a pas de différences de
race avant d'en venir à cet article 1er
les débats ont été longs est ce qu'il
n'ya pas une trop grande tentation des
députés à vouloir modifier la
constitution sur des sujets très divers
et variés comme les langues régionales
ou encore l'écriture inclusive
écoutez le le législateur quand ils
discutent d'une d'un projet de loi
constitutionnelle devient constituants
c'est l'occasion ou jamais de d'apporter
des modifications en profondeur dans le
fonctionnement de nos institutions donc
je crois que le débat doit avoir lieu
même si ça ça prend du temps et même si
et même si ça n'aboutit pas toujours ce
débat-là avait sa place
oui absolument ce débat à sa place et je
crois que la constitution doit être
relus doit être discutée pas tous les
ans bien sûr mais à intervalles
réguliers pour vérifier que ça que
qu'elle garde sa robustesse face face au
temps qui eux mêmes évoluent alors au
delà de cet article 1er en opposition
est très remonté contre cette réforme
des institutions elle dénonce un
affaiblissement du parlement jamais vu
depuis 1958 selon as que c'est le cas
non je ne crois pas que ce soit le cas
je crois que les la copie initiale du
gouvernement était effectivement
peut-être en recul par rapport à la
situation actuelle mais elle a été
largement enrichie par les contributions
des parlementaires et notamment par les
propositions des rapporteurs de ce
projet de loi et je trouve qu'elle est
aujourd'hui qu'elle apporte cette
réforme un certain nombre d'avancées
je pense aussi qu'elle je dirais qu'elle
va rétablir le parlement dans un rôle
qui l'a trop longtemps délaissé qui est
celui du contrôle et de l'évaluation
puisque cette réforme ouvre de l'espace
et du temps dans dans l'agenda
parlementaire pour ses missions là qui
sont essentiels et elle va aussi ouvrir
par par par amendement parlementaire qui
sera discutée la semaine prochaine
l'accès aux données produites par les
administrations afin que le parlement
puisse exercer pleinement ce rôle
d'évaluation justement mais quelles
seront vos moyens
on a bien entendu cette volonté
justement de davantage de contrôles une
volonté des parlementaires
mais les moyens ils seront ils associés
alors les moyens évidemment il ne se
discute pas dans la constitution la
constitution fixe les grandes règles et
d'ailleurs sur la question des données
elle veut même si la constitution
désormais indiquera que les le parlement
doit pouvoir avoir accès aux données
produites par administration
c'est la loi organique qui fixera les
conditions dans lesquelles le parlement
ait accès
les moyens humains les moyens financiers
eh bien nous en discutons avec la
majorité avec les oppositions pour que
le plus rapidement possible le parlement
assemblée et sénat puisse se doter de
telles expertises nécessaires à
l'évaluation de la pertinence des textes
en amont et l'évaluation de leurs effets
en aval une fois que les politiques
publiques ont été engagés autre problème
selon toujours ce nom position avec
cette réforme des institutions la
proportionnelle les républicains
dénoncent le prix à payer du marchandage
électorale avec françois bayrou vous
député modem que leur répondez vous nous
il s'agit pas de marchandage
il s'agit simplement de rendre cette
démocratie française un peu plus
représentative le modem a aujourd'hui 47
députés
il a tous ses députés ont été élus au
suffrage universel comme les je dirais
sans proportionnelle sans de la même
manière les que les députés la
république en argent qu'il s'agit plutôt
d'une sorte d'expérience d'un retour
d'expérience de deux je dirais de la
famille politique à laquelle nous
appartenons et dont françois bayrou et
le leader depuis un certain nombre
d'années qui a la conviction que
d'établir une dose non négligeable de
proportionnelle est la condition pour
éviter la bipolarisation du jeu
politique qui a explosé grâce à emmanuel
macron mais qui risquent de réapparaître
si les ai vus les institutions n'évolue
pas vous le disiez justement doses non
négligeable de proportionnelle à combien
la chiffrer vous à bien la proposition
qui était faite par françois bayrou
s'était 25 quand on est aujourd'hui à
15% dans ce qui était annoncé
nous verrons on en est loin on en est
loin nous verrons lorsque les le projet
de loi organique est une déception mais
ce sera une déception comme ça sera oui
c'était faire remonter ce chiffre on
risque de clients blocage avec le sénat
puisque la droite majoritaire au sénat y
est opposée à la profession
la droite est opposé le groupe centriste
qui est puissant au sénat n'y est pas
opposé le
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
lui même évoqué la dose de 25 % donc il
ya ici et là des soutiens assez fort
pour une dose relevé la proportionnelle
ne sera pas le seul sujet de d'un accord
éventuel entre l'assemblée et le sénat
et donc il faut laisser la discussion ce
faire il faut d'abord voter le projet de
loi constitutionnelle qui ne discutent
pas de la proportionnelle puis ensuite
les deux autres morceaux
le projet de loi organique plus le
projet de loi simple et nous verrons
l'équilibré global
à l'issue de ces discussions et nous
n'en sommes qu'au début d'un long
marathon est les sénateurs se penchent
eux cette semaine sur la loi avenir
professionnel et l'examen de la loi pour
la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel a été quelque peu
perturbée par l'annoncé d'un nouvel
amendement gouvernemental une annonce d'
emmanuel macron lundi elle les
explications de julie boulet ce devait
être la dernière ligne droite pour le
projet de loi à venir professionnelle
réforme de l'apprentissage de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'assurance chômage
700 amendements déposés par le sénat et
voilà que lundi devant le congrès
emmanuel macron change la donne en
annonçant un amendement invitant les
partenaires sociaux à négocier eux-mêmes
sur l'assurance chômage
un changement de dernière minute que les
sénateurs ont très mal pris je ne savais
pas que la fonction jupitérienne
permettait de passer par ce type de
procédure le parlement nous ne sommes
pas un corps intermédiaires madame la
ministre nous sommes le parlement de la
france ambiance électrique hésitations
de la ministre du travail et accusations
de christophe castaner il faut ne pas
favoriser les emballements politique des
discussions nécessaires et comportements
sociaux il a la légitimité du vote
ici au sénat comme à l'assemblée ne nous
inquiétons pas en fin de journée mardi
elle l'amendement déposé par le
gouvernement
objectif une nouvelle allocation pour
lutter contre le chômage de longue durée
un amendement rejeté en commission par
tous les groupes politiques
premier volet du texte la formation
professionnelle et la volonté porté par
le gouvernement de convertir en euros le
compte personnel de formation
si les organisations syndicales ont
unanimement refusé cette disposition
dubitative la commission a décidé de ne
pas s'y opposer
tout en créant une période de transition
pour en restreindre les effets délétères
autre point majeur pour la majorité
sénatoriale de droite
l'apprentissage le gouvernement veut le
réformer en profondeur en y investissant
15 milliards d'euros
si les sénateurs soutiennent la volonté
de moderniser le statut de l'apprenti
pas question pour eux de laisser la main
aux entreprises pour piloter ce
dispositif au détriment des régions
pour moi ça tombe de doute sur le fait
que toutes les branches sont
suffisamment structurée pour organiser
l'apprentissage le cockpit au lieu de
copilotage pardon cela doit se
construire sur une base d'égalité
or là vous affaiblissez les régions pour
donner davantage de compétences aux
branches pris dans des rapports de force
avec syndicats et parlementaires le
gouvernement devra attendre le dernier
mot de l'assemblée nationale pour
débuter la mise en place de ces réformes
sans doute pas aussi rapidement qu'il
l'aurait souhaité emmanuel macron a donc
fait cette annonce durant le congrès ont
souhaité que les partenaires se revoit
les règles de l'assurance chômage à la
veille du début de l'examen du texte en
séance au sénat ce que c'est un mépris
non pas du tout alors d'abord il ya tout
un volet de cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui est confiée à la discussion
des partenaires sociaux notamment en ce
qui concerne justement la question de la
durée des contrats de travail
il a il a annoncé le président de la
république que effectivement le 17
juillet et recevrait les organisations
syndicales pour pouvoir discuter de
cette assurance chômage ça ça ça me
paraît être une très bonne chose il a
également indiqué qu'il recevrait les
100 premières entreprises de france pour
voir ce qu'elles sont prêts à faire pour
est bien accompagné je dirais la mise en
oeuvre le déploiement de ces réformes là
sur la forme le gouvernement a tout à
fait le droit constitutionnel de
d'intervenir pendant un débat
parlementaire sous la forme d'un
amendement dit amendement du
gouvernement
évidemment c'est un petit peu gênant les
sénateurs mais mais ce n'est pas
surprenant puisque c'est un droit
constitutionnel
ce que nous voulons faire en profitant
de cette réforme constitutionnelle c'est
de permettre à ces amendements
gouvernementaux qui arrive un peu à la
dernière minute d'être soumis un peu
comme le texte initial du gouvernement a
des avis du conseil d'état ce qui sera
de nature évidemment à rassurer députés
et sénateurs qui découvre un peu la
dernière minute un morceau du du texte
enfin un nouveau texte que propose le
gouvernement sans avoir j'irai une
expertise juridique derrière donc
évidemment il ya quelque chose de d'un
peu inattendu une intrusion finalement
c'est une intrusion mais qui est tout à
fait possible dans la constitue un tel
que le jeu parlementaire est organisée
nous pensons qu'il faut mettre des
garde-fous le dessus et c'est la raison
pour laquelle des amendements dans un
amendement que je que je porte seront
adoptées la semaine prochaine très
certainement pour encadrer cette
possibilité ouverte au gouvernement par
un avis une surveillance du conseil
d'état
très rapidement sur le volet
apprentissage un cas déclenché un bras
de fer entre régions et gouvernement car
le texte initial prévoyait de donner
plus de responsabilités aux branches
professionnelles au détriment des
régions les sénateurs ont redonné des
prérogatives aux régions le sénat eu
raison le sénat est à une sagesse qui
les a et qui lui est propre et qui vise
à et bien défendre les territoires et
assuré que l'aménagement du territoire
qui compte pour toutes les politiques
publiques y compris pour l'apprentissage
se fait dans les bonnes conditions
ceci étant dit il fallait et je crois
que c'est un élément essentiel de cette
réforme rapprocher les branches
professionnelles de l'apprentissage
puisque bien souvent une des raisons
pour lesquelles on se plaint du manque
de diray d'appétence des entreprises
pour les apprentis est dédé
des jeunes pour l'apprentissage c'est
que les voies d'apprentissage sans trop
éloigné parce que les programmes et les
certifications ne sont pas adaptés aux
besoins des branches professionnelles et
donc il fallait remettre les branches
professionnelles dans le jeu allez on en
vient à ce bras de fer justement entre
l'état et les élus locaux cette semaine
se tenait la conférence des territoires
trois associations l'association des
régions de france des départements de
france et certains élus de l'association
des maires de france ont boycotté le
rendez vous aujourd'hui est ce qu'il y
ait un mépris de l'état pour les
collectivités locales et territoriales
alors de ce point de vue là on peut on
peut soupçonner une forme de posture
politique puisque effectivement trois
des associations parmi les associations
d'élus locaux ont boycotté la rencontre
qui leur était proposée par le
gouvernement mais elles n'ont pas
boycotté le contrat qui leur a été
proposé par le gouvernement puisqu'une
trail très large majorité des
collectivités territoriales des 322 plus
important de collectivités territoriales
ont signé le contrat que le présent la
république le gouvernement et la
majorité enfin en tout cas le parlement
leur a proposé de signer des risques de
sécurité elles disent quand même être
opposée sur le principe mais ne pas
avoir eu le choix de le signer en tout
cas qu'est ce que c'est que ce contrat
ce contrat c'est pas de faire des
efforts inconsidérés ce contrat consiste
à dire si vous n'augmentez vos dépenses
que de fonctionnement que de 1,2 pour
cent par an pas au dessus vous allez
droit d'augmenter mais 1,2 pour cent par
an alors la manière dont l'état vous
vous compensera par des dotations sera
plus généreuse et le principe c'est
évidemment de récompenser les
comportements vertueux si vous ré du si
vous n'augmentez pas trop vos dépenses
de fonctionnement alors vous aurez plus
de dotations
eh bien on va suivre un la suite de ce
braqueur finalement entre les
associations d'élus et le gouvernement
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
jean noël barrot d'avoir été avec nous
cette semaine merci marion merci à voir
rien et puis on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour la dernière édition de
cette saison par le manque d'eau
[Musique]